[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact currently China
boasts the world's fastest bullet train
streaking between Beijing and Shanghai
at speeds of up to 217 miles an hour I'd
like to try that
but now Japan plans to overtake that
record with a new Alpha X bullet train
that'll whisk passengers between cities
at up to 224 miles an hour but as if
that wasn't fast enough the Japanese
also have plans on board for a magnetic
levitation train that will run at speeds
of up to 310 miles an hour if you like
fast cars and you have 1.6 million you
can now buy a hyper speed race car to
drive to work the new Hennessey Venom f5
auto combines a 1600 horsepower
twin-turbo v8 engine with a carbon fiber
chassis boasting top speeds of 301 miles
an hour making it very difficult for the
Highway Patrol to catch you and to give
you a ticket the Boeing aircraft company
has just unveiled plans to build a new
hypersonic jet that can carry passengers
at 4,000 miles an hour you heard me
right that means you could fly from New
York to London in less than two hours or
cross the Pacific Ocean in three hours
the airline giant is joined with
hypersonic specialists to develop a Mach
5 that's five times the speed of sound
passenger transport they hope to see
release into service by 2030 you know
for the last six thousand years the
fastest a man could travel was about 40
miles an hour on the back of a galloping
horse now with high speed trains planes
and automobiles people are traveling
this is in a few hours that used to
require years you know the Bible says
that this might be a sign of the last
days stay with his friends you're gonna
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live you're listening to Bible
answers live honest answers to your
Bible questions this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
Oh here in the capital of California my
name is pastor Doug Batchelor pastor
John Ross is off tonight he's actually
doing a wedding and he was gonna try and
make it back but they're having fun at
the reception so we're gonna with our
engineers do our best if you call and
you don't get through right away just
let it ring and our operators will take
your calls and the order they come in
we're going to start the program as we
always do with prayer father in heaven
thank you so much for your word that
gives life I pray Lord that now as we
explore the truth of your word people
will experience the freedom that you
promised results because the truth will
set us free bless the program to your
glory in Jesus name we ask
amen also want to take a moment not only
to welcome those who are listening on
one of 300 different radio stations as
well as satellite radio across the
country but those who may be
watching the program on our Facebook
feed that's both at the amazing facts
Facebook page and the dud The Bachelor
Facebook page and there you can not only
listen you can watch if it's that
edifying you're welcome to don't look
and see what happens here in our humble
studio with that lengthy introduction I
thought I'd just tie something off with
our amazing fact talked about the speed
now of the trains and the planes and
it's amazing you can actually buy a
factory built car now that will go 301
miles an hour I don't know what you'd
ever do with a car like that other than
get in trouble you know there's some
prophecies in the Bible that seemed to
indicate one of the signs of the last
days well let me read it to you Daniel
chapter 12 verse 4 but you Daniel shut
up the words and seal the book until the
time of the end
many will run to and fro and knowledge
will increase well we are living in a
day where people go to and fro farther
and faster than any other generation in
history my grandfather was born in New
York City where they still rode horses
around the city and he was born at home
and now look at the space station and
the technology of the world and it's
clear that something different is
happening
I even think of a prophecy that seldom
read and a little book of Nahum name
chapter 2 verse 4 that shariats rage in
the streets they jostle one another in
the broad roads
sounds like a Southern California
freeway they seem like torches they run
like lightning once again that's a name
to for you know a lot of signs that we
see happening in the world today seem to
indicate we are living in the last
generation for me one of the most
dramatic is where Jesus said the gospel
of the kingdom will be preached in all
the world for a witness to all nations
then the end will come and now through
the internet what we're doing right now
through radio television and CD the
gospel of printed page the gospel is
going to the world we get mail from all
over the planet there's hardly a place
now from the Middle East to China where
the gospel is not
Trading I think that's one of the signs
if you'd like to know more about the
signs of Jesus coming
we have a special Illustrated Bible
lessons where the great amazing facts
about the second coming we'll send it to
you free you do have to ask though the
name of it the ultimate deliverance
lesson is called I want the lesson on
the ultimate deliverance you tell them
that when you call and here's the number
you call it's different from the number
to call them with your question here's
the number for our resources or for our
prayer line eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven your Bible questions 800 four six
three seven two nine seven gonna go with
our first call talk to Jackie calling in
California Jackie you're on the air with
Bible answers life hi pastor thank you
for having me thank you my question was
regarding Exodus 425 where God
it sounds like God was speaking to kill
Moses and then when his wife circumcise
their son he changes his mind or he
doesn't do it I was just wondering if
maybe this is a similar event to when
David sinned with Bathsheba and their
son died and when God asked Abraham to
sacrifice their son Isaac know that I
think this is a little different
situation it's interesting that you
would ask this question because I
actually spoke about it publicly
yesterday in this very verse funny how
God does that Moses had been called by
the Lord to now lead the people out of
Egypt this is an exodus after he's
accepted the call he's going with his
wife towards Egypt from Midian and it
says the Lord was stood him in the way
to kill him now first of all if God
really wants to kill you do you think he
misses this is aim bad no so it's
basically saying that god that he didn't
the moses was in danger of severe
judgment it's kind of like when the
angel stood in the way with Balaam to
kill him the angel could have killed
Balaam if he wanted to it's just saying
that you're on the wrong path and you're
your eternal life is at risk
God had told Moses I want you to lead
this people Abraham's children out of
Egypt
but the Rite of circumcision was a
covenant God gave to Abraham Moses had
never fulfilled this in his own family
and he had two boys and he kept thinking
y'all do it but support or maybe didn't
want him to do it she thought it was
barbaric or whatever then there's
probably some things between the lines
you have to look at because the fact
that when finally he circumcised his son
then the angel let him go Zipporah gets
upset and she says you're a bloody
husband you know you can see there's
something happening between the husband
and wife there and so Moses you know God
saying look you're supposed to be an
example to my people you're gonna lead
them you're gonna lead the people that I
made this covenant with Abraham and you
have not practiced it in your own family
and God had been convicting him and
Moses had been ignoring it so the angel
met him on the way and said look I'm
serious now this is severe disobedience
that's what most commentators see
happening behind the scenes here okay um
is that then why his wife told him you
were a bright scream of blood to me is
that because that's where I was
wondering if maybe this was a sort of a
Christ so we're sort of because I know
that David son died sort of three days
sort of how Jesus did yeah David son
died after the Bathsheba incident
David's son really died because of his
sin the son of Moses did not die
they simply circumcised him okay yeah he
wasn't slain there is no correlation no
well you know you've making me think
that there's maybe some more spiritual
meanings I haven't thought of because
this is an example of you know Moses on
his way having to perform this Rite for
his son it is something of a symbol of a
sacrifice there I hadn't thought of
before but I don't think I'd compare
with David and Bathsheba because David's
son did die because of David's sin but
good question the outset people read
through Exodus and they stop here and go
what is this all about because it just
kind of it's not really clear pops out
hey I appreciate your question Jackie
thank you very much okay thank you
you're welcome
and we're gonna be talking next to Chris
in Florida Chris you're on the air with
Bible answers live Chris maybe
you have your phone you didn't Chris you
there Chris in Florida
can you hear me Chris is we're gonna put
him on hold we're gonna go talk to Robin
st. John's Michigan and you're on the
air with Bible answers life hey pastor
Doug hi my question is from a Zechariah
chapter 14 okay
and it's verse 4 so it's talking about
Jesus standing on the Mount of Olives
and I well this verse didn't seem to
make sense for a students and to make
sense in context to the 3rd we see then
verse yeah doesn't seem to make sense in
the context of the 3rd coming it's
talking about half the city going into
captivity and then verse 18 discusses
God punishing Egypt so I'm just kind of
missing where this I thought this is
third coming and then it's kind of also
talking about maybe some sacrifices
later in the chapter so maybe you could
clarify that them I'll do my best you've
got roughly four apocalyptic prophets in
the Bible Daniel are a Daniel is one
revelation is another Ezekiel is one and
Zechariah is the other they have these
visions filled with symbols the
apocalyptic visions they see are not in
chronological order they don't give them
that way you know when you're reading in
Revelation it is jumping from scene to
scene to scene and you see that
happening and it is actually a couple of
things in Isaiah that are even like that
but in Ezekiel Zechariah 14 is talking
about the last days but it's not all
given in chronological order when it
says Jesus feeds stand on the Mount of
Olives
you know many commentators believe
that's at the time when he comes and the
New Jerusalem settles into this vast
valley that has formed it does tell us
in Revelation about a war that is raged
after the New Jerusalem comes down it
says gog and magog are rallied against
the people of god and and there's this
big battle that takes place you know
that all fits in here with Zechariah but
what confuses some people is where it
talks about that the houses are rifled
and the women ravished and half the city
goes into captivity this is what
happened actually with the fall of
Jerusalem
Rome so you're seeing a combination of
different prophecies in chapter 14
whenever I see to be very honest
whenever I see Zechariah 14 I think it's
so hard to explain this whole chapter in
three minutes we you know try to budget
about three minutes to answer a question
because it's a deep apocalyptic prophecy
for several verses and it jumps around
that's the best thing I can tell you is
that you have to read this in segments
for let me give you an example just for
me to say that you know the prophecy
that you read in Isaiah where it says a
woman will conceive a virgin will
conceive and bring forth a son and
you'll call his name Emmanuel you go to
Matthew Matthew says that's a prophecy
of Jesus we'll go back to Isaiah read
what it says before that and after that
and you realize it's also talking about
a battle between northern Israel Syria
and Judah Mathew somehow through the
Holy Spirit was able to lift that one
verse right out of the rest of the
dialogue and say this is a clear
prophecy about the second coming but you
go back read Isaiah what it's happening
around that and you can see that he's
jumping around that happens in some of
the apocalyptic prophets okay well that
makes a lot more sense the Isaiah
comparison it's good all right hey
thanks so much I appreciate that thanks
for your call Robert I wish I can see I
can't me this year but I'll be working
in campus oh well hey we'll miss you
there but pray for our presentations you
take care thanks if you enjoy hearing
solid biblical answers on Bible answers
live you can have those same insights at
your fingertips through the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful Maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy-five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 72 75 for life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm or
call one eight hundred five three eight
seven two seven five alright gonna talk
with noah noah calling from illinois
Noah you're on the air with Bible
answers live hey Doug I love your daily
devotionals and my question is is there
any record of female angels in the Bible
and are they biblical
well I don't think so I gotta say this
carefully there is one vision you know
we were just talking about Zechariah and
I think there's one vision in Zachariah
where it talks about these two women
with the wings but it's a vision it's
not saying they're angels and the two
women are carrying a basket and it's
just a whole separate vision you know
you got a leopard with wings too so when
you have one of these visions it doesn't
mean there are women angels now here's
my reasoning it's very basic what's one
of the things that makes a woman
different from a man well her body is
designed for procreation is that right
yeah I mean you know women have two or
three different biological functions in
their body men do not have a woman's
body is designed for birth and nurturing
and to say that there are female angels
would suggest that angels procreate like
humans and Jesus emphatically said
angels do not marry nor are they given a
marriage God creates angels angels do
not get married and have babies so to
say there are women angels that creates
a problem
there's no example in the Bible where it
calls an angel a woman their way says a
man of God it's always in the masculine
terms it's kind of like Annie days a
year won't be like the Angels when we
eliminate procreate you know
yeah the earth is going to be filled
with the redeemed I don't know that
we'll be having new marriages and new
babies in heaven that's at me no that's
what Jesus said you know I've seen lots
of paintings where angels are depicted
lots and lots of them as women
because you know women are so nurturing
now there are things you know angels may
protect children and do some nurturing
things but there's no example of women
in angels can a woman appear as a rather
can an angel appear in many different
ways yeah you know angels suddenly
appear they can appear like a man and
the later reveal they're an angel the
Bible says some have entertained angels
unaware in Hebrews so you know God can
speak through a donkey is there's no
limit to what an angel can do but I
don't see any example in the Bible of
women angels now you know yeah what
mazing facts produced we produced a
program called cosmic conflict and where
these Angels have a war and I wasn't
there one day and they had to get enough
actors to act out this war and when they
couldn't get enough men they started
grabbing some of the women around there
and said here can you be an angel so we
got men and women angels yeah it's not
quite biblical anyway hey thank you so
much Noah for your question I appreciate
it oh you're my pastor I know you will
all have to wave it to you next time
okay
you know thank you so much no I
appreciate your giving us a call and by
the way I do have an sermon you can read
you can read you can watch on YouTube
you just go to the YouTube type in Doug
Batchelor angels and I've done some
things where I talk about the truth
about angels appreciate your call all
right we're gonna try let me see here
all right chase is calling from Houston
Texas chase you're on the air with Bible
answers live
good evening pastor Doug evening thanks
for calling thanks for taking my call my
question is in regards to Galatians 3:29
what is the promise that we are heirs to
being Abraham's seed well you know God
says to Abraham I think there's several
promises for one God said to Abraham
that in blessing I'll bless you and so I
think there's a blessing he also
promised you've got like three different
places where God renews the covenant
with Abraham one is he says lift up your
eyes as far as you can see north south
east and west this will be your land
ultimately God is gonna create a new
heavens and a new earth and the meek
will inherit the earth the seed of
Abraham the spiritual seed of Abraham
people of faith they will inherit the
earth so that would be another promise
the Covenant of circumcision that God
gave to Abraham Moses and Paul basically
say it's now circumcision of the heart
that God once said we were born again
it's the new covenant I will create and
I'll put a new heart within you I don't
know if you're fishing for a particular
answer you're just really asking me if
I'm I don't know if I'm firing where
your target is well uh I guess I was
looking for some specific promise that
was made to Abraham first one is Genesis
12 where God calls Abraham and says come
out walk by faith I will bring you to a
new land and it was basically being
willing to separate from his whole known
world and by faith follow the Lord and
then God says I will give you this land
Abraham looked for a you know a city
that had foundations whose builder and
maker was God so he's really looking for
the spiritual promised land in the world
Abraham was a pillar in his whole life
he dwelt in tents but he's you know
Jesus is going to build us mansions I
see that that makes sense that answers
my question I appreciate it and then one
more you you know one more that I
shouldn't have left out I think it's
Genesis 22 and Abraham offers Isaac that
is one of the most striking examples of
the the faith of Abraham he put his
greatest treasure his son on the altar
and those who have faith in Christ are
willing to lay down their lives take up
their cross make they'll sacrifice
everything jesus said if you love father
mother sister brother houses lands son
or daughter more than me you're not
worthy of me and Abraham passed that
ultimate test of faith by putting his
greatest treasure on the altar for God
of course God gave it back and you know
Christ said no man for sakes anything
for me except he'll get a hundred times
more in this life in the world to come
God said to Abraham because you have not
withheld your son from me I am blessing
I will bless you
and when we make that sacrifice we
receive that blessing of faith as well
that makes sense it doesn't make sense
thank you for your time all right thank
you very much taste appreciate your call
very much let me see here we're gonna
talk to our gonna talk to may Lane in
Fort Pierce Florida may Lane you're on
the air with Bible answers live
good evening pastor Doug good evening I
don't have a question about Daniel 12
for some reason all these years I've
studied the Bible and I never saw verse
11 and 12 I think when it says 1290 days
and 1335 days and something about the
daily sacrifice option the abomination
of desolation and I don't understand any
of that I mean all right well I tell you
what I'm going to do I will give you a
short answer you you've just picked a
question that has the most time
prophecies in it Daniel chapter 12 it's
got three different time prophecies 1260
1290 1335 and I almost need to give you
a history lesson to answer that because
it's clearly a deep prophecy at the end
of the book and I have a lesson I'll
send you but let me give you a brief
answer several times in Daniels
prophecies Daniel chapter 2 January 7
Daniel chapter 8 and 11 and even part of
12 he talks about this great abomination
power that will persecute God's people
in the last days it starts out with the
Roman power that destroyed Jerusalem
they desolated the temple and then it
talks about a spiritual power that would
sit in over the Church of God showing
himself that He is God he sits in the
temple meaning your body your church is
the temple of the holy spirit this beast
power Christ said when you see the
abomination of desolation stand in the
Holy Place as written by Daniel the
prophet Christ tells us to read Daniel
the prophet to find out about this
abomination of desolation and then jesus
said whoever reads let him understand by
the way that's Matthew 24
so even Jesus refers back to this
chapter talking about a great period of
apostasy and persecution that would come
on God's people both the Jews in the
church let me send you a lesson that
explains it
and it's a heavy-duty lesson it's called
who is the Antichrist because this is
the power that Daniels talking about
okay I was wondering is does that verse
11 that says from the time the daily
sacrifice is taken away and the
abomination of desolation set up yeah
does that mean from one to the other is
1290 days or is it yeah this is this is
a prophecy that's saying from point A to
point B and if you want to know better
what that represents okay so when when
did when did the daily sacrifices stop
what's that one the temple was destroyed
seven the idea was that something else
you've got the the literal sacrifices of
Israel stopped well it stopped the day
that Jesus died on the cross remember
the veil was ripped in the curtain well
yeah as far as God was concerned but the
Jews kept right they continued sacrifice
until the temple was destroyed in 70 AD
but I tell you what let me send you that
lesson called who is the Antichrist
anyone out there if you want to
understand this better it's basically
it's very clear lesson but it's
Protestant theology about the Antichrist
power and if you call the number eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven we will send that to you mailing
or anyone else that would like a copy
ask for who is the Antichrist number
again 800 eight three five six seven
four seven I'm gonna see if I can
squeeze half a question in before we
take our first break Chris in Florida
you on the air now yes can you feel I
can why don't you state your question
and let's see how far we get I may need
to finish your question after the break
what is your question about in Jeremiah
31:31
when Jeremiah talks about new covenant
with Israel yes what it doesn't include
Jesus
in discover not absolutely
matter-of-fact Jesus is included in the
old covenant nobody is saved without
Jesus would you agree of course yes
anybody that's being saved now the old
covenant was when God said to the
children of Israel he gave him the Ten
Commandments and they said all the Lord
has said we will do see the Old Covenant
was based on their promise that we will
do it but most of them failed to do it
he said I'll make a new covenant based
on my promise I will write my law in
your heart and I will put them in your
minds hey we've got to take a brief
break Chris I hope you'll forgive us and
we'll come back to you after this
listening friends don't go anywhere we
just need to do station ID for our
stations around the country more
questions on the way stay tuned
Bible answers live we'll return in a
moment
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on earth every life the
cosmic conflict if God is good if God is
all-powerful if God is love then what
went wrong four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm or
call one eight hundred five three eight
seven two seven five one to know God's
plan for our world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 seven two seven
five written by the hand of God and
spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com every bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of god's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 copy that yeah
I just called you're sorry you got one
more part of your question yes because
hey romans 5:10 relates to it romans
5:10 king the dos outside of Christ they
are God's enemy aren't they yeah well
jesus said if you're not with me you're
against me are you wondering about how
does this relate to the Covenant when it
says those without Christ well because I
would like to talk briefly
about my Jewish friend who is like 93
years old and she never accepted Jesus
as the Messiah so are you wondering if
that means that any Jews that did not
accept Jesus as Messiah are they
automatically lost is that your question
well they will not be saved well I would
be careful not to say that because first
of all God looks on the heart and there
are people maybe that did not ever
understand the claims of the gospel they
maybe did not understand the mission of
Jesus let me give you an example and
this would be the scripture that I'd use
is if you look in Acts chapter 19 if you
go there to acts 19 and I think it's the
first few verses it is Paul is that
Apollo's Paul why lipolysis at corinth
paul goes through the upper course of
ephesus he finds some disciples and he
says did you receive the Holy Spirit
when you believed they said we've not so
much as heard whether there is any Holy
Spirit now these are disciples of John
the Baptist they didn't know about Jesus
he said what were you baptized they said
John's baptism and he said Paul baptized
with a baptism of repentance saying the
people should believe on Him who was
coming that is on Jesus when they heard
this they were baptized in the name of
the Lord Jesus now isn't this
interesting here's some people they were
believers they're disciples they were
maybe Jewish believers up on Ephesus
Paul looks upon them as saved disciples
but they hadn't heard about Jesus and so
there may be loyal believers in God that
are walking in all of the light they
have we've got to be careful not to say
that they're automatically lost if they
haven't had the whole message preached
to them jesus said if you did not see as
in John chapter 9 you would have no sin
but now that you see your sin remains
sin is knowing to do good and not doing
it even Apollo's was out preaching the
baptism of John the Baptist preaching
repentance he hadn't heard about Jesus
and he had to get sat down by Aquila and
Priscilla then he understood a lot more
so there are people we can't judge how
much a person knows thank you very much
Chris
make sure and ask for that book on why
the old covenant failed and we're gonna
talk with become that's calling from New
Jersey become you're on the air with
Bible answers live hey how are you Doug
pastor how are you doing doing great in
your question tonight yeah obviously
there's been you know laws passed in
Alabama and Missouri the abortion ban I
was wondering what does the Bible
pacifically say about abortion well
you're not going to find the word
abortion in the Bible because the
practice was not as such is not
addressed what you do find in the Bible
is that from the moment of conception
that was considered a child or a human
some examples of that would be when
Bathsheba discovered she was pregnant
and this is fairly early in the
pregnancy because David still thought he
had time to cover it up by getting her
to sleep with her husband so it must not
have been very far along see what I'm
saying she says I am with child she
doesn't say I'm with some kind of fetal
tissue she looked upon it as a child
when Mary goes to visit Elizabeth and
Mary is now learned that she's pregnant
with the Messiah Elizabeth is pregnant
with John the Baptist it says John the
Baptist Mary says the child leaped in
the womb at the tidings that you know
the mother of my lord should come to me
here John the Baptist is still within
Elizabeth and he's responding joyfully
at the proximity of the Messiah in Mary
and so it's almost like the the two
babies are communicating with each other
you know life is sacred if if life does
not begin at the point of conception
when you get all of the DNA of the man
and the woman and they reform the new
individual that embryo has all the
essence of what that person's hair color
is going to be their blood type their
eye color and a million other features
that's all right there in one cell at
that point so you know if we start
saying well it's okay to abort a baby
because it's only you know five months
basically what you're saying is because
it's small
it's insignificant you start thinking
like that and that would mean that you
think that short people are less
significant than tall people you know
man is made in the image of God a man
and woman come together they become one
flesh and they procreate in the image of
God so a man and a woman who are married
you know has to keep going until they
can't have any more kids I always wonder
that like the the church always says oh
you got to keep going until you till you
know you can't stop
oh you mean keep having children no
that's a whole different question
abortion is long abortion that's a
different right right birth control is
something separate you know there are a
lot of methods of birth control that
prevent conception but once the baby is
conceived that is sacred human life and
once we go down the road of saying that
we can decide whether or not we're going
to protect or preserve human life I know
I think eventually you can start making
some of the same decisions that were
made in Nazi Germany where you say these
people are not significant human life
must be treated as sacred that's you
know that's what the Bible says so but
that's different question then saying is
it okay to plan your families I think
Jesus said you know if you're gonna
build a tower count the cost as you know
first so don't have a bigger family then
you can support and it doesn't mean
every time that a man a woman come
together intimately is only for the
purpose of procreation Bible doesn't
teach that either you know people
continue to have intimate love well they
don't have to have children every time
and thank the Lord there are methods to
avoid that Oh real quick can I get in
one more question if you don't mind yeah
real quick one because we have people
waiting when you agree that that we
should have universal health care for
people who you know who can't afford a
doctor I mean nobody should really have
to die because they can't afford to see
a doctor when you agree with that um I
would agree that in a prosperous country
now you're asking me as an American I've
been around the world where they just
can't do universal health care because
the governments are corrupt in bank run
but if you're asking me in our country
can there be some measure of healthcare
for everybody I would say that's the
ideal but to say that everybody deserves
everything I think you got to be careful
because let me just give you an example
let's suppose that I smoke and I drink
and I use drugs and I'm totally
irresponsible with my health but I want
you to pay for all of the medication and
operations that will result from my
irresponsibility shouldn't I have some
accountability for my choices of course
yeah I think when you once you go down
the road of saying that everybody should
pay for everybody's health care I think
that needs clearer definition because I
think that the ideal is that you live in
a country where either through some
government support or some agency people
can get certain basics but I don't think
that you can promise everybody a
Cadillac you know what I'm saying yeah
you got to be I think we got to be
careful going down that road but now
you're asking me kind of a political
thing so I'm I'm not any good at that
but thank you very much become we
appreciate your question who do we have
lined up here we're going to talk to
Laurie from Minnesota Laurie you're on
the air with Bible answers live I passed
your dog I thank you for taking my call
and I want to let you know you've been a
real blessing in my walk with Jesus and
well thank you good evening mm-hmm my
question is loved ones in heaven so I
have loved ones and they don't love me
back what's your opinion on that you
mean will they be in heaven or I know
the answer probably well you have people
your family you mean that you feel like
you're not getting equal love yeah are
there people in the world that sometimes
don't love God yeah
does God love everybody oh and yeah you
know God is love Jesus wants us to have
his spirit one of the hardest things is
to love people who don't love you back
and Christ made it pretty clear he even
wants us to love our what our enemies
it's not easy but he wants us to love
everybody yeah you know and in heaven
everybody in heaven is gonna ultimately
have God's Spirit they're gonna learn
how to get along and it won't be there I
hope I'm answering your question and
that's about the best night
came up with - it's been pondering me
for about three years I finally called
in to see what you said yeah well yeah
you know the the essence is John says my
little children love each other it's
easy to love people that are lovable
it's a little more work to love those
who aren't lovable but God wants us to
even love them and it's a constant
effort some people say I don't go to
church - the people are not always nice
well you need to go and love them anyway
you know we all need to learn to love
each other
alright we're gonna talk to Andrew
calling from Kansas I think Andrew here
on the air with Bible answers live cover
friend books me not and he says that
basically are you believing this team I
mean women birth Giants and he says
basically and second Peter 2:4 it talks
about that God didn't spare the king and
cast them to hell and then turn darkness
change and he says that none of the
Angels Darwin and the ones that gave
birth science and a yeah
the Giants are the ones that are the
evil spirits
that's death that's just argument
against that it was that Bible verse
those word you said some light on that
I appreciate that yeah you know some
people take a verse in Genesis chapters
Genesis chapter 6 where it says the sons
of God saw the daughters of men they
were fair took them wives of all they
chosen and then they have these
offspring that are Giants and they think
those sons of God are angels it doesn't
say they're angels you see there were
two groups of people in the world Cain
took his wife one of his sisters no
doubt and they went they separated from
Adam and Eve Adam and Eve had other sons
and daughters you read in Genesis 5 Adam
and Eve's next son was called Seth they
all remained true to God they were
called sons of God they continued
serving God Cain and his family they
turned away from God they were called
the children of men as long as they were
separate the sons of God were holy but
the sons of God saw that Cain had some
beautiful daughters and they began to
intermarry it's not talking about angels
because Jesus had angels do not marry
angels or spirits they do not procreate
with humans
there's no example of that anywhere in
history that's sort of the Rosemary's
Baby concept which is not true you know
I have a book I'll be happy to send you
a free copy of that Andrew and it talks
about the angels and the Giants and the
sons of God and it's called who are the
sons of God and if you are anybody if
you want a free copy of the book on who
are the sons of God then call 883 five
six seven four seven and we will give
you a free copy Andrew that answers that
question about the dark angels 808 three
five six seven four seven asks for the
book on the sons of God you're listening
to Bible answers live this broadcast is
a previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time call us at
talking to Linda calling from
Connecticut Linda you're on the air with
Bible answers live hi blessings to you
pastor Doug and to all your viewers well
thank you appreciate your calling in
well I thank you I have a question about
the sanctuary and actually it's a
two-part question
one is was there a hierarchy of trees of
course there was by but we're there real
priests underneath them and then also
with all the lambs that the children of
Israel brought in to be to the sanctuary
for special types how in the world did
they do that
like during Passover where there were
thousands thousands of sacrifices and
they all did it but nine and three I
think yeah well you know you can even
look in whole I think it's I think it's
first Kings chapter two it talks about
Solomon offered like a thousand
sacrifices and you're thinking wow
that's a lot of butchering going on but
they had a whole army of Levites that
would help with that and there were
priests the sons of Aaron were all from
the tribe of Levi but only the sons of
Aaron could serve as priests or the high
priest was there a hierarchy yes it
usually worked so that the elders the
fathers of the other priests they would
serve based on age and experience that's
the way it worked with Aaron and his
sons and but yeah during the Passover
they would sometimes enlist the help of
the Levites only the tribe of Levi could
do these things in the temple with the
sons of Aaron and they had an assembly
line is the only way to explain it where
people came in and they had all the
priests lined up at different stations
and they were stoking this altar with
wood and they were sacrificing not all
the sacrifices were burnt some of the
sacrifices they actually shared with a
priest for food oh yeah so it depending
on what the sacrifice was an example of
that where you see the priests actually
got to eat some of the sacrifice was you
read in first
and you'll read about the sons of Eli
but yep you'reyou're asking some good
questions how did they pick priests well
there's always just one high priest they
had to be the son of Aaron and it kind
of went down through a family line but
thank you very much let's see here we're
gonna talk to James James is calling
from Michigan James you're on the air
with Bible answers live mr. Derek how
you doing good thank you I got a
question concerning Hebrews chapter 6
about starting about the fourth verse
I've never have ever gotten that clear
answer to my satisfaction if they're
talking about the unpardonable sin let
me read this for other people listening
James okay cuz probably more than half
of our listeners are on the road
somewhere driving it says in Hebrews
chapter 6 verse 4 for it is impossible
for those who were once enlightened and
they've tasted the heavenly gift and
have become partakers of the Holy Spirit
and I've tasted the good word of God and
the powers of the age to come if they
fall away to renew them again to
repentance since they crucify again for
themselves the Son of God and put him to
an open shame and the question is is
this speaking of the unpardonable sin
well if a person reaches the point where
it is impossible for them to repent yes
it would be the unpardonable sin but
does this mean that people who were once
saved and they backslide they can't come
back no it doesn't mean that because he
got too many examples of people in the
Bible like the prodigal son who was in
the father's house he back slid in a big
way but he repented and he came to
himself and he came home you've got
David who was obviously filled with the
Holy Spirit he was a child of God and
then he sent terribly with Bathsheba had
Uriah murdered but he repented and he
came back so this verse is not saying
that a person who is once spirit-filled
cannot return if they backslidden samson
would be another example spirit filled
but his closing prayer God refills him
with the whole
spirit so he must be saved
matter-of-fact Hebrews chapter 11 says
that Samson saved
what is this verse talking about I think
it's describing a person who is
persisting and turning away from the
best that God has to offer you notice
the words in light and tasted the
heavenly gift partakers of the Holy
Spirit tasted the good word of God the
powers of the age if they fall away and
this is basically saying if they reject
if they turn away to renew them again to
repentance
you know once a person is just saying
look God gave me the best he has to
offer and I'm just not interested it's
so hard to renew those people to
repentance again they they hardened
their hearts yeah and that's what we
need to be careful you know not to play
games with the Holy Spirit and to make
sure we're listening to the voice of God
when he calls us if God can fix us about
some sin in our life we can't keep
putting it off that's the devil's favor
strategy or we need to repent of those
things praise God lots of examples in
the Bible of people who did backslide
and they came back home yes there are so
hope that helps a little bit yes it does
it makes a lot of sense and I appreciate
your time thank you very much appreciate
your call James and that frees up
another line if you have a Bible
question
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com for
life-changing christian resources this
@af bookstore calm let's see her we're
talking to next i'll talk to talk to
Jesus in Chicago is it Jesus or hey
Seuss
yes it takes hey soos hi you're on the
air with Bible answers live your
question tonight
hey brother dud thank you I want to ask
how would I be able to have full
assurance that Jesus is keeping the Ten
Commandments through me every day well
why are you wording it that way that
Jesus is keeping the Ten Commandments
through you does that mean that do you
think that you can be knowingly breaking
his Commandments but he's still somehow
keeping it through you in an invisible
way uh no I would just like to well I
see that Jesus tells us that if we love
Him to keep his Commandments so correct
I just want to be making sure that every
day I am abiding in him and keeping his
Commandments does an apple tree have
apples because you call it an apple tree
or because it is an apple tree because
it is an apple tree correct does a
Christian have Christian fruit because
you call him a Christian or because the
tree has changed because the tree is
chain so when we're born again the Bible
says if we abide in him we live a
different kind of life
whosoever abides in him sins not now if
you say oh man I've sinned I must not
abide in him it means if you're
continuing to abide in him makes it
difficult to sin you will have the
fruits of the spirit if you are focusing
on Christ Christ says in John chapter 15
abide in me and you will bring forth
much fruit and so as we continue to take
time every day in prayer praying to him
through the day walking with the Lord
spend time in his word if we by His
grace are doing our best to share our
faith with others as we have opportunity
Christ is gonna live out his life in you
and you're gonna see that sin is gonna
be it's gonna be painful to you because
you don't want to hurt him and so you're
walking in his Commandments this is the
love of God that we keep his
Commandments and His commandments are
not Grievous that's what John tells us
okay this or am I am i answering your
question okay thank you very much
brother good yeah thank you very much
appreciate that hey Suz and let's see
we've got time for maybe one more quick
question all right uh is it Leanne Alan
a California first-time caller
no Manila I'm sorry and your question
we've got about two minutes okay I
looked up the word Israel to see if it
meant overcomer because that's what I
understood but in fact it means israei
means a whole that light or air comes
through and l of course is God so I'm
wondering where does it the overcomer
part come from well I think the word
Israel
it means prince with God the term
overcomer is something that was really
attached to the name Israel afterward
because Jacob would not let go he
prevailed with God and God said you know
from now on your name is going to be
called Israel because as a prince you
have prevailed with me you've you've
wrestled you would not let go you claim
the blessing and so that was actually a
definition that got attached to the name
Israel after the fact
can I give you another example of that
real quick yeah when you say somebody
is ruthless that typically means they
have no compassion right yeah that's
because of Ruth in the Bible is known as
a compassionate person to be ruthless is
to be without compassion
well the name Ruth originally didn't
mean that it's some kind of other
Moabite name so but because of her the
name took on a new definition yeah yeah
if I call a person Benedict Arnold
you're calling them a traitor
so in Revelation when it refers to
overcomers is that not synonymous with
Israel and I didn't check that so I'm
not know it is well yeah I think that is
spiritual Israel they are made up of
over comers right okay all right so the
why does I'm looking you know you I'm
looking it up just real quick I'm
looking up the Hebrew definition and
Israel means he will be a prince with
God a contender with God he strives with
God a soldier of God this is a pretty
thorough
it's the exhaustive Bible Dictionary of
names by Cornwall Judson Smith and
staleness Tillman so and that's the one
I often refer to but you type that in
Israel does mean a prince with God or an
overcomer a contender with God and so
everybody it even is right there in the
definition an overcomer with God all
those who are overcomers in the New
Testament in Revelation they they strive
with God they don't let go I will not
let thee go except thou bless me I hope
that's the prayer of everybody out there
listening hey we run out of time for
questions tonight I hope you've been
blessed by the program I think you
probably know we're only on the air
because people like you appreciate it
they go to our website they click they
help us stay on the air
god bless friends we'll talk to you next
week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
a divorce but that's when God led them
to an amazing fax broadcast and there
they saw the biblical view of marriage
as presented annoying Jesus
finally they understood what it meant to
love sacrificially like Christ and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that you've
learned and it's easy to make a donation
just visit
give dot amazing facts to RG or send
your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight you can also give us a call
at eight seven seven five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one thank you for tuning in to Bible
answers live and don't forget to share
with others the amazing Bible facts you
have learned here today written by the
hand of God
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors 12 part sermon
series on the 10 commandments by calling
805 3 8 72 75 or visit AF bookstore com4
life-changing christian resources visit
AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWF ax0
RG and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
you